bonsoir il est 18h pour ceux qui nous
suivent en direct nouvelle édition du 7
8 lecture le journal de la rédaction et
ce soir il sera question du président du
Conseil général des Yvelines qui répond
au rapporteur de la loi sur la réforme
territoriale un tel projet nécessite
d'interroger le peuple l'opprobre et
jeté sur l'institution départementale
par cette réforme pierre Bédié ne mâche
pas ses mots et le conseil pour réaliser
des économies de supprimer la métropole
du Grand Paris il sera aussi question
des hôpitaux et des cliniques qui
disposent de comité de surveillance les
usagers ils sont de plus souvent de plus
en plus souvent représentés par les
associations de consommateurs à quoi
servent ces instances quelles sont leurs
pouvoirs explications dans cette édition
et puis le collège Sainte-Thérèse de
Rambouillet a travaillé cette année sur
un court-métrage au profit de
l'association Lorette Fugain et dont le
regard change sur les personnes
atteintes de maladies c'est la base de
cette histoire dont nous parlerons
plateau avec réalisateur et comédien
amateur
mais tout d'abord cette information
concernant ce cuisinier de 43 ans qui
avait tiré depuis sa fenêtre de son
domicile avec un pistolet à billes
vendredi dernier à Versailles un enfant
de 6 ans avait été blessé la justice
vient de se prononcer l'homme amateur
d'arbre adepte de jeux de guerre passera
six mois en prison pour violence
volontaire aggravée
derrière la réforme territoriale la
disparition des départements si les
contours de l'Île-de-France ne devraient
pas évoluer elle les conseils généraux
qui la composent subiront bien le même
sort funeste dans le reste de l'hexagone
et dans les Yvelines l'actuel président
du conseil général n'apprécient pas
cette situation
2020 le compte à rebours est enclenché
les départements ne devraient pas
survivre à la réforme territoriale
l'État en simplifié le mille-feuille
administratif et faire des économies
quitte à sacrifier les conseils généraux
qui transféreront leurs compétences à 14
nouvelles régions une disparition que
les principaux concernés ne sont pas
prêts à accepter l'Assemblée des
départements de France vient de voter
contre et dans les Yvelines pierre Bédié
se fait entendre dans un courrier daté
du 26 juin le président du conseil
général sollicité par le rapporteur du
projet de réforme s'interroge sur
l'urgence dans laquelle semaine les
débats il souhaiterait la mise en place
d'une consultation populaire comme
l'aurait fait le général de Gaulle et
n'hésite pas à parler d'un projet aussi
mal ficelé que bricolé jusqu'à la
dernière minute pour lui supprimer les
conseillers départementaux n’amènera pas
d'économie mais un éloignement des élus
du terrain et de regretter la
disparition des conseillers territoriaux
installés par le précédent président il
n'a été question que de défaire ce que
le gouvernement de Nicolas Sarkozy avait
édifié peut-on lire le bras de fer se
poursuit donc même si dans sa propre
famille politique leur n'est pas à
l'unité sur cette question Valérie
Pécresse candidato régional en
Île-de-France pour l'UMP souhait elle la
disparition des départements et non pas
en 2020 mais dès à présent
politique toujours et à l'UMP énoncée un
peu plus sur l'au-dit commandé par le
trium vira Fillon Juppé près de 23
millions d'euros dépensés en 2012 en
congrès et manifestation un million
d'euros en 2013 pour des dépenses de
voyage et un déficit qui frôle
finalement les 80 millions d'euros en
partie au bord du gouffre pour de
nombreux cadres de cette formation la
députée des Yvelines chef de file de
l'opposition dans les Yvelines Valérie
Pécresse estime qu'il faut nettoyer
l'umpl dit ne pas avoir soupçonné ce qui
se passait elle a par ailleurs demandé
le remboursement des billets d'avion
payé à Nadia Copé pour accompagner son
mari Jean-François s'il est avéré bien
sûr que ces sommes ont été indument
versées notre question du jour que vous
inspire cette situation actuelle vos
réactions c'est au micro dès l'Audi
moines
je suis scandale oui ça ça nous
interpelle quand même quelque part
on croit plus beaucoup en
tous ces hommes politiques considère
qu'aujourd'hui l'environnement politique
actuel fait que c'est pas très étonnant
de voir toutes ces histoires voilà on
aimerait un petit peu plus de politique
impliquées dans la vie des gens et pas
impliqué dans la dans la leur
donc
j'espère que ils vont faire un
changement complet de tous les gens du
MP des abusés
pas étonné
le monde dans lequel on vit c'est un peu
un peu un peu comme ça c'est le reflet
de ce qu'on vit on va dire j'aimerais
bien
y soit inéligible à tout autre sujet à
présent c'est un organe dont on parle
peu dans les hôpitaux la Commission en
charge des relations avec les usagers
l'association
UFC Que Choisir de Versailles vient
d'intégrer celle de deux établissements
du département l'occasion donc de
s'arrêter sur le rôle de cette
commission avec Yolaine Torres
l'association
UFC Que Choisir de Versailles vient
d'obtenir l'accord pour intégrer le
comité des usagers de de nouveaux
établissements l'hôpital privé de
l'Ouest parisien de trappe et la
clinique des Franciscaines de Versailles
ces comités appelaient également
commission de la relation avec les
usagers et de la qualité de la prise en
charge médicale permettent aux patients
d'exprimer leurs difficultés il s'agit à
travers une commission donc d'experts de
veiller à la défense des droits des
usagers dans les hôpitaux on examine si
vous voulez tout ce qui a trait à la
qualité des soins c'est-à-dire par
exemple l'accueil des malades les délais
d'attente le confort des
malades aussi les droits par exemple
modérateur tout ce qui concerne
l'environnement si vous voulez des soins
au sein de cette commission qui se
réunit régulièrement le représentant
légal de l'hôpital le médiateur médecin
le médiateur non médecin et deux
représentants des usagers tout ça sera
en secret professionnel
l'UFC que choisir participe depuis 8 ans
déjà aux réunions de l'hôpital Mignot de
Versailles grâce à cela des mesures ont
été prises dans le domaine des urgences
par exemple on avait vu des personnes
par exemple qui restaient assez
longtemps sans s'occupe d'âne et donc
grâce à notre action par exemple on a
obtenu que une infirmière passe et
regarde si la personne toutes les heures
par exemple voir si la personne son état
de santé n'empire pas la rassurer la
réconforter lorsqu'on interroge les
usagers la majorité n'a jamais entendu
parler de ses comités institués depuis
2002 mais quand on leur explique qu'ils
y voit une réelle nécessité je trouve
que c'est vachement pratique parce que
quand même quand on va à l'hôpital n'a
pas beaucoup renseignement en fait même
au téléphone quand on a pas les hôpitaux
on nous donne toujours pas beaucoup de
renseignements donc et parfois on rate
les choses en fait importante donc ça
peut nous aider déjà améliore les
services à l'hôpital et nous aider comme
des usagers en fait parce que nous on a
toujours besoin de d'informations je
pense que ça dépend des hôpitaux
et que le problème c'est le monde c'est
pas forcément les médecins ou les êtres
soignantes ou je sais pas quoi c'est moi
qui a beaucoup de monde donc ça va être
très dur à gérer après je pense que
c'est surtout un suivi psychologique
qu'il faut vraiment mettre en place le
comité rencontre de ces analyses et
propositions dans un rapport présenté au
conseil de surveillance de l'hôpital ce
dernier délibère alors sur les mesures à
adopter afin d'améliorer la qualité de
l'accueil et de la prise en charge des
patients
depuis le début de la semaine l'avenue
du pas du lacakie le vélo Drôme national
au centre-ville de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux en surplombant la
voie ferrée est fermée à la circulation
automobiliste donc attention si vous
devez passer par là ce désagrément et
qui va durer jusqu'à la fin du mois
d'août doit permettre d'avancer de
plusieurs semaines la réouverture
complète de cet axe en plan de travaux
un chantier destiné à faciliter l'accès
au vélo de Rome à la base de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin également et aux futurs
activités qui vont s'y développer
doublement des voies circulation douce
sont annoncées un court-métrage pour la
bonne cause l'atelier cinéma du collège
Sainte-Thérèse de Rambouillet a
travaillé toute l'année sur un projet
permettant d'informer et de récolter des
fonds pour l'association de l'Orée de
Fugain qui lutte contre la leucémie
bonsoir à Benjamin bonsoir assistant
d'éducation animateur de l'atelier
cinéma de ce collège et bonsoir à Lili
vezouse bonsoir et bienvenue élève de
cet établissement et puis comédienne
également pour l'occasion vous allez
tout d'abord nous présenter ce projet 45
élèves de 11 à 15 ans impliqués autour
d'une seule thématique le regard des
autres face à la maladie de quoi parle
plus précisément ce court-métrage
qu'elle est l'histoire alors l'histoire
en gros c'est donc l'histoire de la
petite Chloé qui est âgée de 12 ans et
qui fait sa rentrée dans son nouveau
collège et donc au départ les
professeurs et les élèves de son collège
la traite comme une élève lambda et ce
qu'il y a c'est que à partir du moment
ils vont apprendre qu'elle atteint d'une
maladie grave ils vont changer leur
comportement et leur regard vis-à-vis
d'elle et elle ça va pas lui plaire du
tout
mais 13 ans un peu plus âgé que la
personne que tu campes dans ce film tu
en as pensé quoi de la thématique et
puis de s'associer de s'engager pour une
association comme leur être je trouve ça
bien de se dire
qu'une bonne cause c'est ce qui m'a
motivé pour
pour faire le casting pour essayer de
d'avoir le rôle l'histoire ça te parlait
ça te tu te sentais toucher justement
par cette bah oui parce que c'est quand
même une histoire assez triste et se
dire que j'allais
un carnet de personnage merci va ça me
faisait plaisir parce que c'est pas une
bonne cause comme je disais et puis bah
c'est très bien de se faire ça pour pour
l'association leur étudiant
l'association est intervenue de quelle
manière à quel moment ils sont arrivés
dans ce projet vous saviez déjà que vous
voulez travailler avec eux pour eux
alors en fait c'est moi qui les ai
contactés au mois d'août l'année
dernière donc je leur ai proposé parce
qu'en fait chaque année je travaille sur
un avec des associations parce que le
but c'est de mettre à contribution
l'atelier cinéma au profit d'une
association donc il y a deux ans on
allait travailler sur les dangers des
réseaux sociaux et d'Internet cette
année on a décidé de faire un film pour
l'association leur étudiant donc je l'ai
contacté moi-même Stéphanie Fugain la
présidente de l'association donc je lui
ai proposé de faire un court-métrage qui
traitait du comportement et du regard
des autres face à la maladie donc elle a
dit il y a pas de souci et du coup on a
lancé un casting au sein du collège pour
essayer de trouver le rôle principal
donc c'est l'idée qui a été élu comment
vous avez fait ce casting justement
alors en fait moi je travaille avec
trois ateliers cinéma différents donc le
mardi mercredi et jeudi donc ça
représente 45 élèves comme vous tout à
l'heure donc j'ai proposé le rôle
principal aux différentes élèves
féminines de mon atelier qui avait 12
ans ce qui avait des plus grandes aussi
mais il fallait la tranche d'âge c'était
12-13 ans donc j'aurais proposé et en
fait elles ont elles ont joué une scène
elles ont joué une scène du scénario et
puis j'ai tout de suite vu que Lili
allait être prise parce qu'en fait c'est
elle qui jouait le plus naturellement
possible et au cinéma il faut être
naturel c'est pas comme au théâtre il y
en a qui jouait un peu de façon
théâtrale et du coup donc c'est comme ça
qu'elle a eu le rôle tout est préparé tu
avais pris des cours avant c'était
entraîné un petit peu j'ai appris le
rôle et puis j'avais fait des cours de
théâtre avant donc je savais à peu près
comment jouer et puis surtout je me suis
entraîné avec mes amis qu'il passait
aussi le casting sur l'histoire même
vous êtes partis avec une base vous
aviez déjà écrit quelque chose et
ensuite ce sont les comédiens
j'ai écrit pendant les vacances l'année
dernière une trame de base et après
certains élèves qui sont un peu
passionnés criture sont venus se greffer
sur ce projet et m'ont proposé de des
séquences en fait qui n'étaient pas
prévues dans la trame de base et qui
sont venus se rajouter comme ça tu as
proposé des choses tu as réussi à
modifier un petit peu les visions du
réalisateur ou c'est difficile non je me
contentais de jouer et d'apprendre le
texte il litière donc un rôle important
le premier rôle celui de cette jeune
fille malade qui va voir l'attitude des
autres changer envers elle voici un
extrait de ce court-métrage
les enfants aujourd'hui
c'est pas grave Chloé installe-toi
tranquillement
j'allais justement commencer une idée
prends une feuille et un stylo
tranquille
alors aujourd'hui on va faire une dictée
un petit peu particulière à partir du
livre de Nabilla vous connaissez
on va voir si vous parlez bien la France
c'est bon
alors c'est parti
allô
point d'interrogation
non mais allô virgule
quoi
point d'exclamation
et nous sommes avec réalisateur et
comédien de secours métrage vous me
disiez pendant qu'on regardait l'extrait
d'ailleurs pour ceux qui veulent le voir
en intégralité et les disponible sur
votre page sur sur YouTube sur votre
compte particulier on peut voir
l'intégralité de ce quart d'heure ce
court métrage vous me disiez ce sont les
élèves qui l'ont proposé cette scène le
livre de Nabilla voilà donc ça fait
partie de l'actualité et c'est des
jeunes qui m'ont proposé de d'intégrer
ce genre de scène pourquoi pas faire une
dictée sur à partir du livre de Nabilla
j'ai trouvé ça super sympa léger mais ça
reste un sujet très sérieux vous vouliez
quelque chose qui reste léger même si on
aborde la maladie le regard de l'autre
je voulais pas du tout faire quelque
chose de dramatique sur la maladie en
elle-même je voulais vraiment essayer de
traiter cette cause mais de façon
humoristique je demandais tout à l'heure
comment s'était passé le travail avec
les élèves avec les comédiens même
comment s'est passé le travail avec le
réalisateur ce qui est difficile comme
réalisateur comment qu'est-ce que tu vas
garder de cette expérience c'était une
expérience plutôt chouette parce que
l'ambiance était bien et puis
je suis pas trop d'expérience avec les
réalisateurs donc je pense qu'il est
bien comme réalisateur
artistique ou autre oui je vais
continuer à te dessiner mal l'année
prochaine peut-être prendre des cours de
théâtre mais pas l'année prochaine plus
tard et puis voilà continuer un petit
peu à jouer pas pour en faire métier
mais un petit peu
de faire le métier elle disait qu'elle
allait continuer cet atelier parce que
l'atelier vous allez continuer le
travail l'année prochaine et justement
on va travailler pour une autre
association qui s'appelle l'étoile
enchantée de Alain Chabat et vous
travaillez donc là pour l'association de
Laurette Fugain il y aura une vie encore
à ce documentaire ce court métrage
pardon il a été réalisé il est diffusé
on disait si on veut le voir sur
internet mais il y aura aussi
éventuellement des projections dans les
établissements scolaires le but c'est de
sensibiliser et puis aussi des
projections pourquoi pas dans certains
cinémas ça a été le cas à Rambouillet
pour récolter des fonds en fait donc la
première partie du projet donc c'était
plutôt un terme à l'établissement c'est
à dire qu'on a voulu sensibiliser les
élèves au don donc on projeter le film
au 750 élèves du collège pour les
sensibiliser ensuite on a fait une
avant-première au cinéma Vox de
Rambouillet pour récolter des fonds donc
là pendant les vacances on va faire une
petite pause et à la rentrée on va
continuer dans différents cinéma donc au
cratère à Saint-Arnoult et puis dans un
cinéma parisien dans le 5e les élèves
ont aussi continuer à s'impliquer
accompagner la vie de ce qu'on appelle
bien sûr
à faire par rapport au film et puis aux
différentes projections le regard de
l'association le Red Fugain ils en ont
pensé quoi on les a pas sollicités ce
soir mais satisfait de ce résultat ils
sont très satisfaits alors Stéphanie il
l'a pas encore vu le court-métrage donc
je dois la voir normalement la semaine
prochaine pour lui donner le DVD en main
propre mais ils sont très appréciés et
puis et puis surtout on a récolté
énormément de dons par rapport à ça là
on est après 1000 euros quand même
donc voilà c'est pas pas négligeable les
élèves ont été sensibilisés au travail
de cette association qui lutte contre la
leucémie le Red Fugain tu en sais
maintenant un petit peu plus puis on
savait déjà un petit peu sur la leucémie
sur cette le travail de l'association ou
ça t'a permis de découvrir autre chose
aussi ma famille de découvrir parce que
je connaissais la leucémie je ne savais
pas vraiment ce que c'était je savais
que c'était une maladie du sang et
leur étudiant ils me sont j'avais
entendu le nom mais si je n'ai pas eu
court-métrage je ne connaissais pas ça
me suffit la sensibiliser les élèves de
votre établissement et sans doute des
autres établissement encore merci
beaucoup à tous les deux d'être merci en
plateau pour ce travail ce court-métrage
qui a été mené avec cet établissement de
Rambouillet le court-métrage sur
Internet et puis le travail de
l'association sur le site aussi de
Lorette Fugain si vous aussi vous voulez
en savoir plus merci encore on reste
maintenant on va parler pardon
maintenant de d'environnement pour la
suite de ce journal avec le Solar
Décathlon qui lui se poursuit
l'association Greenpeace était présente
sur place à Versailles samedi dernier
l'occasion pour les visiteurs de
découvrir leur stand qui comparaient le
coût des énergies renouvelables et du
nucléaire Olivier Maniscalco et
Greenpeace sauce sous l'art Décathlon de
Versailles la célèbre organisation
écologique tenait lors de ce deuxième
week-end de compétition instant de
transition énergétique au milieu des
prototypes de maisons solaires des
maisons solaires qui font partie
intégrante des solutions
environnementales de demain de plus
moins coûteux que le nucléaire
contrairement aux idées reçues si on
compte dans le coût du nucléaire le coût
réel du démantèlement des centrales le
coût des assurances et surtout le coût
de la gestion des déchets pendant des
siècles voire des milliers d'années à ce
moment-là dès aujourd'hui il est bien
évident que le coût de l'énergie
nucléaire est infiniment plus importante
que celui des énergies renouvelables
sauf que malheureusement ce coup-là ne
figure pas aujourd'hui dans le coup du
kilowatt-heure et beaucoup de Français
continuent de croire que le coût du
nucléaire est plus bas que les énergies
renouvelables ce qui est évidemment faux
vidéo explicative ateliers jeux pour les
jeunes ou échanges autour de différents
thèmes de campagne de Greenpeace le
stand permettait au public de s'informer
tout en proposant une pause lors de la
visite du Solar pour faire une petite
pause et pour bah j'ai visite les
maisons et ça permet d'échanger un peu
les idées les stratégies sont pour moi
ils sont claires il faut qu'on réduit
les consommations de 60 70 % de tous
qu'on peut on se rend compte que les
gens ils font ils font ils font tout
pour les bien-être personnels mais très
peu pour pour l'avenir et ça ça démonte
des des visions et des stratégies un peu
plus à long terme
d'ici à 2030 la France a pour objectif
de produire 32% de renouvelables dans
son mix énergétique selon Greenpeace en
leader européen les Français auraient dû
pousser la production à 45%
et puisque nous sommes à Versailles la
ville vient de recevoir le trophée 2014
de la mobilité dans la catégorie espace
public un prix décerné par le président
de la Région
Île-de-France et qui récompense le
travail mené cette fois-ci sur le jardin
des étangs Gobert un lieu réhabilité
pour la promenade et aussi afin de
permettre un franchissement vers la
future gare routière les Trophées de la
mobilité en Île-de-France sont ouvert
aux collectivités entreprises
administration 41 projets déposé cette
année celui de 50 ans en Yvelines de la
communauté d'agglomération a été
distinguée pour sa part dans la
catégorie mobilité nous quittons 50 ans
en Yvelines nous quittons même la France
pour le Portugal la communauté
portugaise qui n'a peut-être pas
beaucoup vibré pendant ce Mondial de
football mais elle n'a pas perdu le sens
de la fête la preuve avec ce reportage
de Mathilde Capvern réalisé lors du
festival folklorique qui s'est déroulée
dimanche à La Verrière
au gymnase de La Verrière musique et pas
de danse portugais résonne à l'occasion
d'un festival portugais le week-end
dernier l'association domino à réuni des
groupes folklorique du nord du pays
jusqu'à un moment de partage et de fête
tout Vienne représenter leur racine
mon grand-père il en faisait donc moi je
dis je prends la relève voilà pour nous
oui c'est déjà d'une part de montrer la
communauté portugaise montrer notre
travail pourquoi pas présenter à
d'autres cultures
instruments principal des Portugais le
concertina un accordéon avec moins de
boutons et les mains indispensables pour
accompagner les danseurs habillés de
leurs vêtements traditionnels
après comme danse donc c'est des danses
folkloriques après on a plutôt les
costumes c'est plutôt le costume qui
apparaissent c'est des costumes on a des
costumes qui font les gens de la ville
les costumes qui font les gens
des villages
il y a des costumes qui font les gens
pauvres mais j'en riches et je pense que
ouais c'est tout ce que ça représente
quoi à quoi ça ressemble
un français on va dire que c'est comme
un groupe breton
les groupes ont une demi-heure pour
chanter et danser aux couleurs de leur
région l'association s'écrit il y a
trois ans et compte bien perpétuer les
coutumes du Portugal
autour de 6000 euros reversés à
l'Association française contre la
myopathie l'ASM à l'issue d'un
vide-grenier organisé aux
Clayes-sous-Bois ce week-end
l'Association pour la lutte contre les
maladies génétiques organisent depuis 9
ans cette opération afin de collecter
des fonds 300 exposants présents malgré
le mauvais temps d'autres rendez-vous de
ce type sont encore à venir d'ici le
mois de décembre afin d'augmenter la
cagnotte qui permettra d'aider la
recherche rappelons que les maladies
rares et les maladies génétiques
touchent de 4 à 6% de la population soit
3 millions de Français et 30 millions
d'Européens
la première année on était petit on a
fait une centaine de places et d'année
en année ça augmente ça augmente
aujourd'hui il y a environ 300 exposants
et depuis un certain temps depuis une
bonne semaine je refuse beaucoup de
personnes j'en suis désolé on essaiera
de faire mieux les prochaines au mois de
décembre on reverse tous les fonds à la
FM dans le Téléthon donc je suis moi par
rapport aux clés je suis le président de
l'association LMG et
la personne qui me remplace à présent
pour le Téléthon est présent sur le
vide-grenier et c'est lui qui reversera
tous les les fonds au mois de décembre à
la FM merci de nous avoir suivi le
journal revient demain mercredi au même
horaires les interviews les reportages
toutes nos émissions également sont à
revoir sur notre site Internet grâce au
replay excellente soirée